should it don't though they don't don't
don't don't you with a poppy do a what's
up rambley dough's Hannibal got a new
episode with the founders of Bonte ma
Tokra and Simone sensor I had the
opportunity to meet them in Boston last
year during the angel Capital
Association conference and though they
were dope I had good ideas and we're fun
to talk to
so started working together and I
invited him on a pike guys to talk about
bond C which is a mobile platform for
women of color to help them find
hairstylist and a fun and engaging way
it's a problem a lot of women of color
have while traveling and they got an app
to help solve that problem so we talked
about you know how they got the company
started how they met their vision their
struggles with hair my vision for myself
with having a fake dread extensions and
it's a good time it's uh you know
different episode for us and different
[Music]
what's up yeah another episode of the
handsome Rambler podcast
I'm your host Hannibal Buress and I am
your co-host Odie trap and we have our
special guests today Maude and Simone
hey hey hi
[Music]
founders of Bonte yes
[Music]
nice yeah that's how you open the show
thank you thank you
warming up yeah how y'all doing I'm good
yeah good yeah the founders of bond see
we met in Boston
yes that's right yeah a CA yeah yeah
what's that a CA what is they CA aims of
capital associations right right on yeah
still get those emails probably dodge
angel Capital Association yes a
conference isn't it's uh it's very boys
we're not very born is very different
different vibes cuz I actually went to
the first day I was it was after a tour
and so I went from you know doing shows
and then the next day I was in this very
corporate environment yeah it was
counted sorry you know the same way yeah
we were probably the only two black
women their color I think it was one
more it was a couple of Dexter dicks you
know I remember Dexter is a very POC
name hey listen man time it's not a
monolith though yeah I guess he's not a
very Asian a there's all you know ya
can't put people in boxes
no yeah I'm sorry let me unbox you there
was another lady from the Pacific
Northwest there was a couple tables down
and I remember I didn't get to talk to
her cuz I wasn't sure if I didn't I was
I didn't know she had a startup or what
was going on I said have reached out
yeah yeah yeah we have our reservations
about being here anyway the only non
famous people ever been here so we're a
little bit worried about filling the
time oh you're not the only non famous
people
we asked some people to yeah yeah yeah
don't worry about it a good time how did
Monty come about yeah sure you can take
it away yeah sure so I I just traveled a
bunch so you know grew up in Boston I'm
from Boston Houston Houston to London
was in Paris a little bit back to London
and Indies sound like a Drake song how
do you spell bond T Beal and NT I so
actually a little story about the name
Simone and I are both gun in and bond of
T and our native language means to braid
her hair so we were like on a flight and
I was saying oh you know what should we
name this and I was trying to say oh how
do you say hair in Latin and how do you
say hair in Spanish I said what about my
own language and whenever you go to
Ghana you always get your hair braided
for the most part so like braiding we're
bringing things together so making it
easy for you to find stylist events and
to build community so bringing different
things together and making one strong
well I'm great out of it so we shortened
it to bond T cuz in tech usually like
one word two syllables yeah so so the
name came from but yeah so we just
traveled a bunch and we were just so
hard to find stylists and people that
could do you know our textured hair and
you know from like chasing people down
the street but girl where'd you get your
hair done and just crazy stories of like
getting your edges like you know
snatched off cuz the braids were too
tight and I was in the back of a lift
and I said okay I can use my phone to
order a car I can use my phone buy
groceries I can use my phone to find a
date like why can't I use my phone to
find you know hairstylist and figure out
how to navigate this and that's where
the whole idea was born and you know was
talking of Simone about it and she's
like yeah so I was living in New York or
I still live in New York so I was in New
York at the time what Mar was like
globe-trotting and she she came to me so
no problem
in the magazine industry specifically
like in the beauty world the beauty part
of it and I'd seen firsthand like a lot
of stylists or hair stylists are out
there and they're aside from like
magazine work editorial work which isn't
even that much but they're also like
actively looking for for clients
especially like the POC stylist who were
like not even getting any like Billings
or credits for what they were doing huh
so we came together kind of talking
about the art separate worlds and vonti
came together as like an opportunity to
not only give clients like people like
us the ability to define me stylist but
also the stylist the ability to market
and promote themselves in a very
legitimate way right yeah we are an out
yes so it's like tinder meets LinkedIn
gotcha gotcha gotcha what year did you
start it up we started okay well we
started talking about in like what 2016
yeah 2016 year so and then once they
officially started this year September
2017 or January yeah well we soft
launched in DC in September and then we
like fully launched in January okay yeah
yeah so super new yes super new this
both for your first venture and startup
world yes yes yeah our first time like
doing the tech thing yes are you guys
from Ghana or no no I wanted to clarify
but then I didn't want to be like a nerd
yeah first generation - OH
Korea South Korea I don't want to sound
like the enemy so no just forth probably
from you know just still in people day
he's a moan I've actually known since I
was seven so we go way back yeah yeah
I'm like God in community or was that
just very much so she thought we were
related like cuz you know how you have
like your play cousins and like our
family knew each other from like the
Ghanian community and our
growing up so like her mom was my aunt
my god auntie Lily but she thought we
were actually cousins until like we were
like 15 or something when I was like no
I don't like we're not cousins wait you
just broke it to her I said hey
stop calling me like no it's not true
right yeah yeah it's cousins I do that I
do that a lot with a lot of my homies
that I know from way back
yeah better Asian I'm like yes my cousin
yeah I mean I think I see you like yes
guys guys dozens but you never really do
that with other relatives you don't like
an older like Asian guy wouldn't ever be
like that's my girl I just thought of uh
you know a parody of the movie colors
what it's cousins cousins closest
closest cousins cousins cousins that's
all I got all right what colors what
colors it's about uh it's a gang movie
oh okay
and about Bloods and Crips have to see
you know wow I don't even know if I've
seen some things in my past was it did I
see that whole thing and it made or did
I just see part of it and just hear
people talking around and I heard about
it so much that I think I've absorbed
the memory and isn't that even my memory
yeah mm-hmm that's how I feel about Star
Wars like I don't think I've actually
sat through like Star Wars without
having to get up or talking through it
or whatever but I know the movie so well
from people always just talking about no
I've never seen Star Wars any of them
like you know talk about Lake and it's
not that big of a deal seen the Goonies
I haven't seen
surprised that you've never seen what
he's like she's never seen anything like
I didn't know if that was a sound effect
I mean it's not that huge of a deal but
it is a huge deal when your baby is
infected with a wood a fire or has been
intruded by you got a virus on you
that's not a virus it's just some stupid
malware that I I freaked that I haven't
figured out how to exit like an exercise
yet yeah yeah whatever we're gonna cut
that all out so known each other since I
was seven
yeah you always have entrepreneurial
instincts yeah I think so yeah we were
always kind of like hustlers like it's
not we used to sell chocolates when we
were little like yeah and we sold those
ice what kind of chocolates you know
that's like little chocolate like okay
like when you're in school when they're
like okay you have to sell this number
of chocolates to go on like that yeah I
heard dad is diabetic yeah yeah so yeah
I would say for me personally yeah I've
always felt like I had that yeah magic
tripping Oriole spirits kind of thing
like yeah I mean I used to sell like
bags of chips like when I was a little
kid so bulk I'd buy like you know get a
dollar from BJ's they dropped me off at
turnaround go to the corner store buy
some chips go back into school like you
know sell some guys I mean you know I
see I see people outside of baseball
games and they're slinging bottles of
water yeah peanuts and I'm like these
guys are killing it mm-hmm like that's
the that's a good that's a good hustle
but you know I found myself like very
judgmental cuz like as a kid I would
sell those things but now like because I
live in New York on the train you see
kids selling like candies and things
like that you know under the guise of
chair exactly well it's basketball team
yeah I don't like the basketball team
ugh sorry yeah now they're hustling
people so I had a friend's birthday
brunch this past weekend and we're
sitting there and had an open like a
window door and this little kid comes
through he's like oh I'm selling cookies
I'm like oh okay you know how much I'm
thinking two three dollars he's like
1099 balls on that kid look it was some
generic brand like I don't know clovers
valley or something I've never heard of
it
but at that point we felt bad so you
gave him $11 for a resident but somebody
else's tenant of it yes the juice so did
you buy out it cuz you already said yeah
well my friends but I was trying to bend
them I haven't we have a start-up so
we're not really like we don't have that
extra income first of all you know we
had a restaurant we fool everything yeah
and your basketball squad yeah this
ain't it man yeah so you all lived a
great school high school and college and
colleges together yeah the job she's a
year older than me so I've been
following on my whole life what college
I went to Emerson College in Boston yep
yeah what y'all still see sales
economics what did you guys study I was
marketing Marlo so you fell right in
there yeah yeah yeah and I studied
marketing and I did radio it's very you
hosted a result she did I did I hosted a
show called the secret spot and it was
an arm being soul show so it was
actually one of the number-one rated
shows in its timeslot that's all yeah
you had like inmates calling in and
requesting yeah yeah yeah
yeah like like prisoners in the Boston
area would like listen to it so they'd
like call us or like write letters like
what uh so what years was this this was
that I was doing to look in the archives
no I wanna give a sense of place yeah so
this was 2010 okay well we graduate yeah
Oh 9 o-- 9 o-- 10 an idol tonight as i
wanted to get an idea of what songs will
play like wahoo like we play like like
The O'Jays like yeah wow it sounds like
we'd play like a nice mix of like
baby-making music some genuine some like
OJ's yeah yeah the 90s did you get did
you do a lot night let me just say 90s
R&B is probably alike like one of my
favorite yeah the ants down yeah like
man yeah Michael I tell you state
definitely not and all this our Kelly
stuff is killing me because oh man do
you still listen to our Kelly though I
don't I don't play I deejay so I don't I
don't play them anymore good yeah and
the furthest I go with our Achilles
sometimes I'll play them it I'll I'll
sing is some of his songs at the karaoke
place but that you know I justify that
because it's me singing our killer it's
not him singing it I don't think he's
getting paid off of that song alright
what man
gotta make good music okay you wanted
said it would guilt nobody was even
judging you you like this is out I feel
guilty because what are your thoughts
he's from Chicago right like with his
star off the ground or like I don't know
if they I was yeah
I didn't listen to the 19 minutes song
yeah I I still haven't I still I haven't
mentally prepared myself for it
just a lot I feel like it's a journey so
you heard a clip of it and no like this
heaviness you get kind of punch-drunk
after well you aren't any substances
while you listen we know nothing no
mostly sober the song itself makes you a
bit drunk yeah cuz it's very he's
pouring his sold out but his and it's
kind of repetitive
and he's saying a lot of heavy stuff how
so how did it make you feel how did it
make you feel after the song was over I
felt I was in a weird place May hurry
too much yeah it was just too much it's
a my team in a song made any compelling
arguments for himself compelling what's
the definition of compelling like let me
think this whole thing's not too young
it was the song but the song is is I
stuck through with the whole song even
though I did take a little break around
minute 12 who Kansas sculpted 19 minutes
straight on a song
yeah well breaking an intermission broke
it up and then I was still kinda I was
feeling fatigued but then I knew that he
close strong musically yeah musically I
knew that they were structurally to do
some type of shift
there's no half-assing with our Kelly
knows for it and he did yeah how will ya
go ahead sorry I'm sorry I don't know
that yeah
also as women how do you guys feel about
listening to our Kelly or plenty I don't
I don't listen them anymore I don't
plays music actually I'm sorry
boycotting yeah yeah well I mean I don't
know how much of a me personally like I
wasn't like a stand for our Kelly before
this and now I still don't listen to his
music yeah put it that way
you're anti are Kelly well it's putting
words in my mouth I just said I don't
want are Kelly come before me um no I
mean yeah I guess I am Antiochus okay
where you sinned I'm not an art Kelly
fan you know poster never was our killer
I was that's why I made it really hard I
mean even you know I go to kinda in that
age time where you're going to ton of
wedding so they'll definitely play you
know stuff in the name of love okay
don't turn it off and you know out there
it's like I'm tempted now let me sit so
you're at the club the place is bangin
ignition comes on lose a [ __ ] you guys
sit down yes my birthday I went to EJ
and I was like nah
that's respectful yeah that's respectful
yeah yeah I mean I mean I wouldn't start
losing my [ __ ] and dancing but I would
probably still continue the conversation
that I'm having with somebody but that
is like a good point of like I had a
conversation with a friend about this
like about Chris Brown like do you judge
a person's art based on like their
personal like people are watching
Emerson College
so was was dear white people based on
your experience um no well I would say
Emerson was a very white college but it
wasn't like so white where it was like
dear white people like it wasn't super
pretentious but was very white ya know I
didn't know actually if anything like I
feel like though that was like a good
bastion of like diversity like doing
things like the radio show and things
like that where there was just like a
very different all t cultural experience
in that respect but the what the rest of
the school was very white yes yeah very
very wait yeah cool what happened after
college I moved to LA for a little bit I
had an internship and a job and I like
worked in the fashion world for a little
bit maude what'd you do just travelled
lived in Houston a little bit you know
the Drake verse so yeah just being an
adult what so yeah I got real jobs and
then kind of pounded the pavement for a
little bit and then we would connect
like I don't know maybe like five years
later yeah after college yeah you prefer
you prefer LA or New York mm-hmm
you know I'm not I realized as I've
gotten older I don't really care for
either oh I like Paris thank you guys
been to Ghana though yeah yeah
then in a while yeah I got it all right
but I don't know if that's the city I
was like take roots in like live live I
like New York I don't love New York yeah
yeah yeah yeah New York yes uh when I
leave for while I lived there for about
eight years and then when I get back I
go this place is [ __ ] insane yeah
it's [ __ ] it's overstimulation but
you know it's good it's gotten so
different in the past decade that it
just it's it's getting to a point where
I'm getting a little tired of it how so
uh I just like the white privileges
gotten out of control
sure it's gotta not like way out of
control
whoa where do you stay like when you
couldn't everywhere I mean all over I
mean wherever wherever you know wherever
I end up I end up and it's just like
that yeah like the last time I was there
yeah man
this is New York like Jesus you know but
the people like but it's you know people
still smart out there there's a lot of
culture it's a world
it's an international city there's so
much good out of it too but the white
privilege is getting out of control
that's all that's all I really have I'd
say that for everywhere like all over
the country like the white privilege is
like not not like New York you know I
feel like I don't know especially like
when you go to an area that used to just
Sharon so culturally yeah you know you
go to like Williamsburg or something
like yeah yeah sure like that's like
historically black and now it is overrun
with like a lot of white people is
extremely expensive now so yeah I feel
you but it's not even gentrification
it's more like privilege yeah did you
hear about that story at that there was
like a bar it's called like some or
something or something like that and
it's run by some white woman who took it
over from what it used to be like a so
let be like a bodega or something like a
bodega known by owned by people of color
in the neighborhood and then she took it
over and she turned it into a
that plays like I don't know like
whatever doesn't matter what it played
but she had bullet holes and she said it
cause like this whole thing yeah I feel
like that's very indicative of what
Brooklyn is right now yeah a lot of
pockets of Brooklyn yeah yeah let's kill
it's got thick it's got bullet holes
like used to be real violin uh yeah yeah
so tell us more about the bond T yeah
yeah yeah but so I mean it's a very
exciting time for the company
you got like a team of people working on
like the tech side and the are you guys
hands I'm working on that too or yes yes
so we yeah we're all kind of in this
together as well you know developers
myself and Simone definitely have some
people supporting us on like some
marketing side has a bunch of interns
absolutely girls are so how many people
on the squad so officially on the squad
me and mod and they're gonna have like a
couple contractors and there we have our
developers who are also contractors as
well but what's also been great is we've
had like a strong squad of interns and
it's just folks that hear about it like
oh my god I love this thank you I want
to be a part of this and that's been
amazing and we'll say okay yeah and
they've been really great at helping
spread the word and support so that's
great yeah that's great um have you guys
come up with a slogan yet yeah dangle
your hair experience I don't know I say
it like duh don't you know but so can
Matt may I suggest one yeah sure you're
ganna look great uh-oh I see what you
did there
Oh Ghana okay and I think I appreciate
it sorry
yeah you just spin it however you want
just yet on that great experience but
yeah it's just great to be able to you
know pretty much like you know sometimes
well maybe not for you guys but you may
see someone walking down the street and
you'll say oh my god I love her hair who
did it yeah and with the app we bring
that to life so you can you know kind of
like tinder swipe right swipe left when
you like a style we tell you exactly who
did it where they are that's not them
you know like right then and there and
also just community where if someone
does their own hair you can message them
and ask them what products they use and
just be able to talk about it and see
what events are happening so who who's
your first stylist sign up that's a
great question ever first one was it
yeah I would say he's probably Quentin
yes one actually one of my hairstylist
in DC yeah a great great guy so
down-to-earth and just sort of shadow
Quentin appreciate you and I mean he's
done like Michelle Williams hair like
Gail you know and killing all those and
he was just like I'm here for what
you're doing and has always been
supportive so that's awesome
yeah what's been the biggest challenges
so far oh my goodness
ice cream we had I mean the fact that
Maude and I are like first-time founders
everything is new to us so it's kind of
like an uphill battle like I always joke
that were kind of failing up like a lot
of great things happen but then like a
lot of show you think happened at the
same time so we're constantly playing
that balance of like being elated and
then being like depressed
entrepreneurship yeah yeah I think aside
from the tech part I think funding has
been difficult for us but that's also
like speaks to a greater issue with
female entrepreneurs especially like
color in their face you know like the
stats are like pretty harrowing and you
see it I think for black women the
average is like 36,000 or something that
women that they raise from like the
capitalist one and then four companies
run by predominantly males it's like
white 2 million or something easy for
like 30 guys it's kind of wild that's
that's the average just for
yes a pretty big like venture can't get
venture capital but there's a study the
Diane project that covers this really
trying to bring more attention to it and
the numbers will just make you sit up a
bit but it is changing it's progressing
it has a long way to go but I know only
in the last I'd say like the last 15
years has it been like because if
anything like actually I think the stat
is that there are more female founders
of color than any other like they're the
highest growing rate of entrepreneurs or
women of color yet they still continue
to get the least amount of funding like
a zero point zero zeros yeah from 2009
to like all the funding that's ever been
put towards it um so that's probably
it's more but it's not even like I think
the funding is also a thing that like
legitimizes you in the space like you
can say I raised a million dollars and
have like nothing like people raise a
million dollars off an idea on a napkin
I'm telling ya so that gives you like a
bit of legitimacy in the space so even
if you have an amazing product like we
believe we have yeah it's really
legitimizing it with the numbers behind
it like saying like oh we've raised this
much money this is often times that's
where like other like venture
capitalists want to see like okay who
else has put in how much have you raised
that's been one of the bigger struggles
for us right but I would say and I was
telling some on this the other day like
entrepreneurship is a bit like a Rubik's
Cube right like you're turning it you
figure out one side you get it all the
same color and then you turn it over and
the other side is completely messed up
like oh my god right and then you're
fixing that side and you just keep
turning and trying and growing and with
your successes and then some things that
don't go well so you get all the sides
right yeah well yeah it's all going so
I'm just gonna say but we had found luck
with funding like people who like really
trust in belief more - and like hop
hopped on and like that kept supported
us but it's more so like then you see
other people next to us the other great
thing especially about being in New York
is like there's a big community of
female entrepreneurs especially women of
color and I see other people with great
ideas and it's like why aren't you
getting funded like why aren't people
like investing in this amazing idea and
it's because you know
that's what charnel exactly yeah and
could you not have like that like a
Patagonia best you know like those shoes
yeah but no works I did what's happening
with pontine getting a girl you guys is
there right do you guys have a rating
system for your stylist like Cheryl she
looks great here but got them she talks
too much reviews and also what we also
go to is we have a bounty certified
feature so between us and our network
you can essentially say I can't sign
that stylist and then they end up higher
in the ratings but yeah I know there's
definitely like about like we've had to
turn away some stylist and we send them
notes right like hey your pictures
aren't meeting where it needs to be or
hey language you're using is not great
like we just see what cussing up in a
constant like while they're doing the
job yeah it comes on reviews because
some people want different experiences
like some folks will say I know
Tiffany's gonna make me wait five hours
yeah but you know yeah lace front is
tight so I'm here I'm a wait but at
least you know what you're going into
yeah right so five hours is bananas done
I agree with if I get out in five hours
and like that's how long it takes today
yeah oh yeah in the sharpening yeah but
we're trying to change that by like
bringing more attention to it right it's
like oh she don't make me wait five
hours I make someone put you on blast
and be like do not go to this woman she
made me wait you ladies aren't that
tight only five hours this is a lived
experience like we had a group whatsapp
between us and are like childhood
friends where that was all it was like
us complaining about this person did
this this person did this to me like but
now and that's like be the forum that
you have is like you and your
girlfriend's but now if we can put this
person like and say hey Cheryl made me
wait five hours don't go to her other
people who are not your girlfriends will
see you and be like okay Cheryl you
change your ways but you're not gonna
get my other Cheryl Cheryl but just to
that point is the other side of it where
someone may not be as well-known and
they'll see the work and be like oh my
god she's amazing like why did I not
know about her book we've had a few of
those instances like we had a really
good friend that was going to Miami
oh we're not good friend like just
person that we knew that was going to
Miami and she want to get her hair done
so she goes on the Bonte app and found
the stylist you've never heard of you
know booked her went in and like got her
hair done and was going I think no
birthday celebration on a yacht
somewhere right but it was just so
seamless for her she hopped on a plane
from DC went down and Von D solved the
issue for her yes yeah now is this only
for women or can a guy go on their look
and get a good faith for right now it's
only for women I mean if you're a guy
who's looking to get like dreads open
more rows or locks it's very yeah yeah I
see you growing it out yeah yeah almost
I'm just trying to get enough just get
fake dreads Fetty WAP has some fake you
just kind of be the bit of luck that's
the noise that it makes that's the noise
I make when I can't explain something
[Music]
[Music]
Jimmy's engage and stop my dress thing
so walk me through that $50,000 20,000
shares what was a typical day
or is there a typical day oh because I
know you travel a lot and say that
that's just a routine a little bit but
when you get your home base there is a
typical day for us I mean it does
involve us talking a lot like wheat so
we're we're in different cities so she's
in DCM in New York but we still see each
other often like we bounce back and
forth but even when we're not we talk to
each other not exaggerating I'm like
maybe in a dozen times a day yeah and
those conversations buried between like
literally minute long conversations to
like two hours you guys are significant
others wear each other's this is
literally ruin dates for me because a
blocker in here
I was traveling to New York I was
delayed all this stuff took me a while
to get there and Simone was on a date I
didn't know but I told her hey I'm like
waiting outside I need the keys I don't
have a way of getting in and I didn't
know where she was because she's super
Shady sometimes she don't be telling me
what I am and she came with the keys and
I said thank you so much and then she
said she was on a day and I felt really
bad but I didn't know oh I thought you
popped up to the dinner with files and
got a new stylist we got a problem
she got a [ __ ] she got a snack a
fuzzy edges bundles two bundles is that
there Cheryl's out of control she's the
dead Rice's chef we gotta get rid of her
no but it was like it just felt like a
bear because I had to like rush out of
the restaurant you know when you pull
that like oh like something there's an
emergency and then he's like all right
and I never heard from him again
right yeah it was it wasn't meant to be
it could have been the wine it wasn't it
was Thursday yeah life would have
respected your hustle or he would have
been like you know what that's sure you
got D you know you're you're a strong
powerful woman with dreams and goals and
I respect you and I support you and
let's get married but it didn't go down
that way but yeah anyway enough about
that so
so typical day starts off a p.m. in
Reverse Mott interrupting your day 8:00
p.m. 9:00 o'clock time to work but I
mean just really focused on covering off
different things occur on tech right
developments a big piece talking with
stylus talking with consumers also you
deal directly with your stylus oh yeah
yeah Cheryl leads are talking to who's
usually the one that does the
recommending yeah yeah okay Matt yeah
what do you say like I'm sure I'll like
I'm sorry I didn't I just at all that's
my first time doing waves what we asked
well what we can do to help right like
what can we do to make sure that we're
setting up Cheryl to win yes right like
you know why didn't you answer the
message or like what happened here and
we hear the reason and we just work
through it so okay yeah if it's
something big but usually to be honest
it's been smoked on would be a pretty
yeah what I'm good yeah okay so dealing
with stylists yeah Dylan trying to form
new partnerships yeah and then going
over marketing plans you know looking
through we have plan coming up if we're
talking with investors and honestly
we'll have a set day like hey these are
the five or six things we want to get on
this is the objectives we're trying to
achieve
and then you'll just get a crazy call
and everything just goes in the back
burner Yeah right like yes where you'll
have a whole day set up that's what
we're gonna do and then you get a call
from an investor saying hey I need XY
and Z and you're like okay right and
everything just stops and you're doing
and dealing with that or you know some
will have a bad experience you're like
okay what happened and then you kind of
Park it or like hey we need you to fly
to LA and you're in Annapolis I guess in
that case for us and you know everything
drops and you go right so who do you all
look to for inspiration for the business
Hannibal Buress yeah no I'm just kidding
I don't know why I said that
Oh Susan
sake yeah I mean I think one of the big
pieces has been our like circle of other
entrepreneurs primarily black female
founders that we call you wanna shout
out some other apps necessarily other
apps but like there's minted they're
great they're a beauty beauty platform
so they do like lipsticks and makeup for
women of color yeah and they've been a
great resource for us and good PYT like
pay your tuition has been a great
company and support and we've been an
accelerator with them so venture crush
it's an accelerator we participated
explain what an accelerator is yeah sure
an accelerator is essentially like an
incubator of where a certain number of
high potential startups will all come
together like you'll get chosen to be in
a excel look like there's a ton of them
they're like Y Combinator this venture
crush there's tech stars those are all
different names of them so they'll pick
high pitch the startups that they feel
like have a very high potential to
succeed bring them together and have
either they take you to like something
like a Y Combinator will fly everyone
out to San Francisco and it basically
had them it's like a bootcamp for
startups where you're meeting with
different people every day you're
talking to different successful startups
you're doing all these different like
they could give you homework even where
you have to like figure out like
different like funnels and ways to
succeed your to grow and succeed your
business yeah yeah and that's
essentially what so the generator is
yeah so through some of those
accelerators what other companies of
venmo is a big one that gave them the
accelerator that were currently in
search box yeah like a lot of off the
top of my head I can't think of other
ones but yeah I know it's like a huge
one yeah succes Larry's are great like I
mean you don't have to necessarily do an
accelerator but they are a great way to
connect with other startups and also
it's like a great way of connecting with
other people in
in that whole scene who or like either
have money connections to money or have
like connections to other people who can
help you out in other ways like with
either if you're doing something in tech
like they know great developers over
they didn't like project managers and
all that other stuff so have you guys
done advertising yet with podcasts no no
you know the right podcast we hear that
yes maybe we can negotiate Stewart your
demo do they fall into the women of
color you probably don't get a smooth 27
girls from hey what's up key Andra in
Arkansas she comments on everything is
it shut up key Andra are you
[Laughter]
but no we are looking at advertising
podcast we love yes I mean that's the
way people absorb like I feel like
advertisements now like I don't you
don't have to watch them on TV because
you have like Netflix or you can
fast-forward and it's so personalized to
especially if you if you were to land
someone like to dog Queens yeah I use
this it's great probably not I don't
know I have no idea what this does stuff
and I might be I might be underestimate
my black female podcast listeners you
know you don't know just cuz yeah maybe
just a few us now yeah just as you don't
see somebody tweet no some don't mean a
net listen people got other stuff to do
besides Twitter tweet actually every
time they hear something you don't I
thought well I think my problem is I
would probably have more Asian followers
if people didn't think that I would
sound like a big fat white guy okay so I
get all the time
so oh yeah but I don't know how to sound
Asian so is there like an Asian like an
Asian and Asian accent and I was trying
to do what is it cuz they have black
said no but no accent what's that Philip
being the least Filipino accent she's my
Filipino accent yeah they politely say I
gotta I gotta trust your neck yeah the
only reference point for Filipino accent
is just a comedian joy koi doing
impressions of his mom like that sort of
sounds like jo koy yeah that's great
there's a comic named Rex Navarrete I
know yeah he specializes in Filipino
comedy it's just straight up
yeah thoughts of my Filipino culture and
he does the accent well I mean he is
Filipino so the accents in him but he's
[ __ ] hilarious I love him check him
out I might check it out yeah Gretchen
Everett I mean he's no legend or
anything but he's a legend in my mind do
all comedians kind of know each other
do you like feel like you guys all like
I know each other personally ya know who
each other is that you like comedians
like you'll be like do you know this
person isn't your like yeah I know him I
know yeah me you'll see the name if you
can't follow Stan or even like if you if
I play a comedy club I got a friend
playing a comedy club sometime let's go
well I'll just look at a comedy clubs
calendar just to see who's working at
the spot you know so I'll just see all
this person working so you'll know
people's names even if you haven't met
them personally or and looked up the
work you just see all that person plays
these venues or you sorta have yeah I
mean there's some people that and I like
to just be aware of my business because
I just like to see oh who's sorry I'd
like to compare a competition
yeah well that will I just also just see
you to see what people are charging for
tickets so you kind of I kind of gauge
that for cert cuz you charge different
ticket prices in different cities
sometimes depending on on the market and
what your demand is in that place so
I'll see all such as such is charged in
forty bucks in this city I definitely
can get 40 bucks or maybe I'll go 35
here or somebody's charging right 25 in
a city that means you say your ticket
price yeah you set your ticket back so
please
yeah that's a good gauge I didn't know
you that that's pretty cool yeah you
gotta look and also unless you know just
I've learned to even not even just
comedians with with music acts I've been
to venue websites and I'll go through as
if I'm by one of my own tickets I'll go
through to see what the ticket fees are
that's like my ticket fee the service
charges like 12 bucks or some [ __ ] now
go check another artist is playing a
week some musicians some I never even
heard of I just like what is that ticket
fees and then this dish is like seven
bucks so I hit up I have two ways I hit
up the road to say what the [ __ ] is up
with these fees and why is it did it
made me realize that a lot of stuff like
that is super arbitrary so y'all just
make an up [ __ ] so I changed my make
mine as low as you can
or I'm canceling the show okay it gets
to a point where it's not even about
profitability it's just about greed yeah
like it's funny cuz like we're sensitive
to price but also not that really not
really cuz like you might be sensitive
to like a $35 surcharge but you'll spend
like $800 on your weave like it was a
little bit too like I was telling
investor once I said you know one of my
cousin's makes $30,000 a year but she'll
have like a $600 weave in that shows
every month yeah somebody needs a fade
that's paid salary yeah 30000 can I get
that $20 and I mean it kind of changes
your whole attitude like you know there
are times where you just won't go out
because your hair is not done and people
will say what like yeah you just don't
feel good so you'll stay in yeah here's
my jobs around that so you will make the
concessions needed to like make sure
your inherits looking out so you won't
pay maybe same bill yeah yes now do you
guys stay in a in a certain like bracket
like is it like only you only deal with
high-end style a bag of weed you know
maybe so we don't know we don't know not
to do that yeah the pricing is very
clearly listed so we like one of the
things we pride ourselves on is like we
are a very hair positive and we don't
necessarily we don't judge on what you
want to do we just help you facilitate
that service positive exactly or you
want like a like a crazy heart not crazy
but a hard hairstyle with like a
waterfall or something or you wanna
think like whatever you want actually
finger weights are really cute right now
as you start seeing all these everything
people are booking you know coming back
like hey I could pull it off
yes but probably I have some gel in the
some jams I'll probably work some magic
on that actually does if you got finger
waves like you I'd be killing it behind
so yeah yeah actually I have we have a
stylist and she works magic on any type
of hair salon first all right
Asia no it is an Asian hair like the
hardest or crystal a very specific so
yeah
yeah yeah so cut a little bit you cut a
little bit and burn it no no cut a piece
and then you send it set a stylist ahead
of time so she can let ya know she could
put it on a little doll head work with
it a little bit then you come in to
works see you like I've been I've been
waiting for you yeah I've always wanted
to grow a fro but I just like if I grow
my hair it goes straight down but I
don't you get a perm yeah I get a pic I
mean you got a do a perm it's too much
yeah I pick it up no if you don't pick
my hair it'll do literally put some
product in there pick it up no it'll
just look like wet stuff in there not
that easy bro I'm trying to tell you how
to how to do this man Marty I'll figure
yeah go to the body forums go to the
forum say hey I'm a nice man 37 years
old trying to get a fro trying to go
from your fro slight midlife crisis I
been a crisis I'm trying to get a throw
my prince trying to get dreadlocks
acceptance yes yeah you look great
I'm Pro Hannibal dreadlocks yeah yeah I
would too if I could you could do that
I'll do that [ __ ] in the club cuz I have
you hate me my father's and I'll be
hatin but I got a song is wow it looks
so lit like when waka flocka is doing
that it looks so lit it makes the sock
so much better
black oh yeah and [ __ ] did you need
you gotta be in a dance
yeah just like a head banger you cover
up dancing bet if you got two dreads
just flow and is done just do whatever
with everybody strike them out of dress
like a little yacht do you guys ever you
guys ever go to uh you guys all receive
like a heavy metal band life like a hair
because they'll don't go on to the
breakdown like to do and then it's all
hair it's all and it looks amazing cuz
now synchronize it's the same thing but
with dreadlocks that's right yeah yeah I
got an idea for the app okay lay it on
us you know on some of these dating apps
I hear on these apps do you hurt I heard
what you're here bro
I hear there's some sound like a person
can connect their their Spotify oh
that's what you heard see when that
profile yeah you just kind of see the
music sure yep what if the stylists had
their the music playing so that's
something we've talked about where I
don't want to give too much way but oh I
even talked to you about it yeah but I
talked about with our intern yeah where
we do like playlists for like certain
hair related experiences like say you're
taking down braids like that's like
three out a minimum three hours like you
want a playlist that I'll help you out
do that yes much time yeah it's washday
or like for whatever experiences it is
so yeah if you guys did a whole
experience like okay we're gonna do
everything from your fingers to your
toes to your hair to your clothes
oh that rhymed yeah you wanna turn
around verse there I wasn't ready with
the instrumental for it
[Music]
my drum machines [ __ ] up sound guys
yeah fingers to the toes yeah we have on
her make a class what we found is a lot
stylus like yes so they like hair and
makeup nails we haven't really dipped
into that much dye list that's a like
another kind of a call it the whole
shebang bang box the full shebang
Mangano super Italian sign where's the
bang what's the etymology sue bang I
just use it and that's not Italia it's
just the whole thing
that's the black women a [ __ ] with
shabang shabang no it's two bangs the
whole shabang shabang
yeah and that shooting that I did down
just riding you guys guided it around
the corner you know what I'm saying yeah
that idea's run into a wall I'm saying
hey you gotta check out my my my my my
catchphrase my god I look good
get the full shebang bang that's it yeah
that's right yeah that feels like of one
of those terrible commercials like yeah
like oh yeah car dealership come here
you gotta look good make sure
now it was broke yesterday
Oh Oh making up for it yes so it's a
relief I just had yesterday I just had
to talk and it's honking yes no you have
you have bonded with that machine so
much to the point where it's like if
it's not there for the show you have
like a nervous breakdown okay
what do you mean was break but I think I
wasn't myself I needed it to wake me up
a little bit hold of conversation cuz
you imagine it was a good thank you and
some good lovers thanks so much
look I think y'all very sharp and
focused and I'm happy to be working with
thank you yes oh yeah where he's trying
to have you on it's right you're yes
very excited to have you I gotta been
great thank you gonna do great [ __ ]
bang bang
Nosa bang bang let's see here here's
that'sa bang bang might be for somebody
else
you know what I'm saying like oh yeah
like a car detailing place yes something
else do you want just a straight wash
and wax or you want the full shebang man
yeah for Superman for somebody else cuz
you know you know I uh I forget who made
the the B for goosebumps by Travis Scott
hmm but uh that producer he shafted so
if you are Mike will made it I don't
think it was Mike will but that beat I
think Kendrick got that beat Drake a few
of the big artists passed on that beat
but Kendrick ended up on the song though
oh yeah Kendrick get it up on the stage
Drake there's a few other big people
that the cat that beat yeah yes so Chris
bang bang bang bonzi go to Google with
that see you know Inc yeah okay
yeah I'll come up with something for you
but I'm sticking with shebang
what well thank you all for coming into
so any closing words download bonds on
instagram at bond t app yeah for the
full shebang that he Oh
hashtag full shebang bang yeah yeah but
then we check out von tbo and nti mmm
look tinder for textured hair yeah
they're yeah they're you gossip Thank
You cool yeah thank you guys
[Music]
[Music]